this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 17 with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink take two
the first take that we just did which
you all don't get to hear Echo Charles
had a coughing attack
there it is right seven seconds deep
into the podcast he started coughing
uncontrollably he's still kind of
coughing a little bit
well good evening it was a good evening
until you
had a level nine coughing and Outburst
good evening good good evening look how
smooth that was we're all clear all
right what's up everybody hey so going
down the rabbit hole little rabbit hole
of the psychological
experiments
listen can be there's some revealing
going on and I know you like that word
revealing yes reveal so
last of the last ug we talked about this
experiment called The Ash experiment
where they took the eight people put
them in a room seven of the people were
actors they would make an assessment of
something and the seven people would
give the wrong answer and then the
eighth person who was the subject of the
experiment oftentimes they would they
would give a wrong answer to they just
kind of fit in Conformity right
Conformity interesting stuff we can
learn about ourselves and we can learn
about a team in a group so it's stuff to
pay attention to another experiment I
think that gives us some good
information
about ourselves and about others
and I've talked about a version of this
one but I hadn't heard this particular
version there's a psychologist in the
late 1960s
name is Martin Seligman I think that's
how you say it and he was he was
actually looking at operant conditioning
of dogs like Pavlov's dogs where you
ring a bell and then you feed them and
eventually they get to a point where you
ring a bell and they start automatically
start salivating they know what's coming
right so how do you condition
animals and then how well does that work
with people and he was doing a different
experience experiment where he was
ringing a bell and then the floor that
these dogs would be on would give them a
an electrical shock I'm not going to
talk about the humaneness of this
experiment it doesn't sound real Humane
to me to start shocking dogs especially
because I like dogs so here we are we're
shocking dogs but that's what happened
we're reporting on it we're not doing it
we don't support it actually no
so they're shocking these dogs
and ring a bell shock the dog ring a
bell shock the dog and eventually the
dog's Behavior was as if they got
shocked even if they didn't shock them
they're so used to getting shocked
getting tense that they would act that
way even if it didn't happen
okay so does that experiment
and then he puts a wall
like a like a divider in this in this
room this dog room with electrical
floors
but one side of the of the floor the
other side of the divider there's no
shocking on the floor so you so now he
puts those dogs in there
and start shocking him again
and they don't jump over the wall
they don't jump over the wall the Bell
Rings they get shocked they're like they
sit there and they get shocked
they don't and the Wall's not high this
isn't even a challenge this is just like
a very low effort Escape
so what's going on why aren't they just
trying to get out of there
so then he goes okay well let me try it
with some fresh dogs so then he took
fresh dogs
put them in there
and as soon as he shocked him the first
time you know what they did they all
freaking jumped over that divider and oh
okay cool it's safe over here so this is
not something that dogs couldn't figure
out where where we're standing sucks
maybe over there we know it sucks here
let's go to where it doesn't suck
So what had happened was
was that
they had learned the dogs had learned
well the the phrase that they call this
is learned helplessness
you learn that there's nothing you can
do about your situation yeah look we're
getting shocked that's just the way the
Bell Rings we're gonna get shocked
there's nothing we can do about it and
they lose the bigger view of the world
so
that's
a very interesting thing to figure out
and the way that they they take that
view and again these are views they take
this idea
and some people apply it
to
the way it impacts humans right and one
of the ways it impacts humans one of the
examples that they talk about again
these aren't
this isn't a fact this is what this is a
hypothesis that some people believe some
people believe that like clinical
depression comes from a situation where
people no longer feel that they can
control anything that's going on around
them they don't have any more control
over their fate anymore
they're they're they're
perceived absence of of control is what
it ends up being and then what do you do
you what do you do to fix yourself
you don't do anything because you don't
think that anything you can do will help
your scenario and that kind of reminded
me
again this is why this this story stood
out to me it reminded me of that story
that I also told on the Underground
when I was in Iraq and there was that
family living in this one room
house big room but it's one room and
they had a sewer trench just Raw on the
floor sewage in between like their
kitchen prep area and their dining room
table and and
you know I was confused by it and
why would you not try and fix it and I
thought maybe there's some of this in
effect there think about this
this is 2003 2004.
for Generations
Iraqi the Iraqi people had been beat
down by this tyrannical leader Saddam
Hussein where they have no control over
the Fate it's like just what it was is
what it was
they had no will
had no will to try and figure out how to
escape the situation that they're in
or at least obviously some of them
and and what this boils down to also
then it the other thing that stood out
to me about this experiment it's the
opposite of extreme ownership right
it's the opposite of extreme ownership
with
with extreme ownership you look at a
situation you go look this is on me
I'm gonna take control I'm gonna fix it
if you don't think that way if you have
learned helplessness then you think
there was nothing I can do about it
nothing I can do about it as you know
this isn't my this isn't nothing I can
do about it
and you can get you can that that that
attitude can get beat into you
and it might look man life is going to
put some things on you that are going to
be out of your control
and sometimes you fight you know you're
young and something happens and you
fight against it doesn't matter it
doesn't help your outcome and then that
happens again you don't make the
football team whatever you try to gain
weight and you can't I'm just thinking
of like things you might have faced that
beat you down right sure yeah thank you
but it happens to everybody
right oh my parents are getting divorced
I try and help I can't I'm just at oh
now I wanted to live with my dad now I
gotta go live with my mom nothing I can
do about it
my my mom's
my mom's not here very much she's
working all the time I'm by myself
nothing I can do about it
the food that I'm getting isn't good
nothing I can do you see where I'm going
with this you can learn that nothing you
do is going to have an impact
which is obviously bad because this is
this gives more meaning to the to the
saying what is it get knocked down six
times get up seven right that's like the
saying it's incorrect by the way because
you can't get up you need to get knocked
down seven times to get up yes but yes
correct it provides that actually is a
very meaningful idea yeah because you're
gonna get knocked down over and over and
over again and what you have to watch
out for
is that you don't learn that you're
helpless
that's what you have to watch out for as
another as I read a little bit more
about this later on
with Neuroscience they found out that
helplessness is actually the default
mode
so what you're born with is a default
mode that I can't do anything and then
we learn
that we can control things that are
going on but then depending on your life
circumstances you may
relearn to be helpless
as opposed to some people that are like
oh you know what they you know think of
those little positive reinforcements
when you take control in a positive
outcome comes yeah
that's awesome
that's awesome I feel pretty lucky in
the fact that I felt when I would do
something and take action if I got beat
I would kind of shrug it off
and if I won I'd be like yeah
right I mean the most absurd example of
that is me saying that if I'm on a
airliner and it gets blown up in sky in
the sky yeah that I am going to you know
figure out a way to assemble some kind
of a parachute scenario on my way down
or I'm gonna get into a you know I'm
gonna do something yeah I'm gonna find a
pool to get into that's gonna have a
cover on it's gonna I'm gonna do
something and we're gonna be good
that's absurd
that I think I have that much control
over my outcome
yeah in a plane in a plane that's
crashing right it's kind of absurd but
as an example right I so so it's just
things that we need to watch out for
to make sure it's something to think
about for two reasons and this is the
same thing I said about the ash
experiment there's two reasons to pay
attention to this
and look you know what there's there's
all these when they do these experiments
there's all these
counter experiments there's people that
that debunk the experiment and they they
do a bunch of things
regardless
there's a lesson to be learned and it's
a lesson to be learned on two fronts in
my opinion the two fronts are me and
everybody else right I want to make sure
that I don't ever learn helplessness I
wanna I'm gonna pay attention to make
sure I don't learn helplessness
I want to make sure that I don't ever
teach helplessness
have you been around people that that
have a helpless attitude like they they
don't think that anything that they do
is gonna matter yeah I have been around
those kind of people yeah don't you feel
that so when you're um obviously you
didn't make do the experiment but when
you think about the people that you know
don't you feel that it's kind of a
spectrum where some people they're just
really like that and then some people
they're like that sometimes or under
certain circumstances but other times
you know they're not or whatever
um but yeah and I think there's a good
balance to have I mean obviously you
need to if you think you can control
everything and you can't then you turn
into some kind of a psychopath if you
think you can't control anything and you
don't try then you're turning into
whatever that is but it's not good so I
think the extremes on both of these are
something to watch out for yeah
but
I think the worst one would be I'm I
there's nothing I can do that's going to
matter yeah
nothing I can do will impact
what's going to happen in my life that's
a that's a horrible thing so I want to
make sure I never learn that myself I
want to make sure I never teach that and
I and then so that's externally I also
want to be able to pay attention to
other people what if I see this I go oh
I know what's going on
my friend
doesn't think that they can have any
impact cool what can I do to show them
what can I do to show them get them a
win and then reinforce the win
right what can I do to get them a win
and reinforce the win there's another
there's another experiment where they
take rats and like put them into a tube
and basically if a rat wins once
he's way more apt to win again
against another rat and the rat that
loses is much more apt to lose again so
there's another little
psychological thing and and in the book
what's that book
outliers outliers the kids
that are older on the hockey team on the
soccer team on the football team the
kids that are older
because the you know how they do the age
cutoff is you know if you're born in
whatever so if you're born in January
and you're the oldest kid you got what
you got a 11 months
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we
mobilized
Underground